Welcome to "Ear Biscuits".
The podcast where two livelong friends
talk about life for a long time.
I'm Rhett.
And I'm Link.
This week at the Round
Table of Dim Lighting,
I finally get to hear
about your spring break,
epic road trip with your.
Oh man.
With your oldest son.
You did the,
you did the "Long Way Around,"
just in America
like a few months back.
You went from North Carolina
back here to California
on a you and Locke road trip.
And I've done the long way
down from Maine to Miami.
Yeah.
Shout out to Ewan McGregor.
You weren't on motorbikes
like Ewan McGregor.
No, and Apple was not
interested in documenting it.
No.
And you're gonna document it now.
I looked into it.
And you're document it now
auditorially for me.
There's been a number of times
we've gotten together with friends
and they've asked you about your trip,
and I really appreciate the fact
that you completely shut them down.
Yeah.
'Cause I was in the room.
I'll tell you about.
He's like, you'll have
to listen the podcast.
I have a podcast.
I'm excited about it.
I'm excited to tell you about it.
It was a good trip.
So you preserved this experience for me.
It's gonna take a while.
As well as you.
There's a lot of details.
All right.
But let's get into it.
But I do also want to remind
you that our television show,
yes, we have one of those,
"Inside Eats With Rhett & Link."
Yes.
Remember,
it premieres on Sunday, April 24th.
This could coming Sunday
as you're listening to this
if it's fresh.
10:30 PM on Food Network.
It's also on Discovery Plus.
And the version on Discovery
Plus has extra scenes in it
because you don't have
to abide by any rules!
Eat it up.
On streaming.
"Inside Eats With Rhett & Link"
Our show is premiering!
I'm excited.
Yeah.
This come the Sunday.
All right, tell me about your thing, man.
This is ambitious.
I like it conceptually, you know?
Well, you know, the
funny thing is, is that.
Maine to Miami.
I didn't have any road trips
planned at the end of 2021.
Uh huh.
The first road trip that
I talked about last time
was a complete,
just circumstantial thing
of kind of being forced
into it in a sense.
And we had such a great time that we,
initially we wanted to go to like,
you know, we Locke and I
wanted to do spring break trip,
spring break trip, like in Japan,
but then that didn't happen.
And then everything got slowly like,
paired back to just remaining
in the United States.
And it was like, well, let's go to Maine.
And then let's go to Maine turned into,
well, there's a college in New York City
that I'm interested in,
so that turned into Maine to New York,
turned into, well, we got that
new cabin in North Carolina.
If you hear little rattling,
Barbara is walking around her,
I don't know if the mic's picking it up,
but just don't be alarmed.
It's not like.
It's not your chains.
My dentures are not about to fall out.
They're,
it's Barbara.
And also,
so we got the place in North Carolina
so then it turned into
Maine to North Carolina
and then Locke was like,
well, what about that school in Miami
that I'm interested in,
that I'd like to look at.
So that turned in.
That's a lot farther
than North Carolina.
That turned into
Maine to Miami,
and I also like the alliteration of
the Maine to Miami McLaughlin marathon.
Oh!
And so we just went with it, man.
So you ran.
Yeah, it was all on the foot,
actually all on skateboard.
How many days total was this trip?
Just to kind of set the parameters.
It was seven days.
So seven days,
less mileage than going from
North Carolina to California
and more days.
So we did North Carolina
to California in five days
and we did Maine to Miami in seven days.
Barbara, you're gonna have to settle down.
Just take her, take her collar off.
Yeah, I'm gonna take her other collar off.
Come here, come here, come here,
come here, come here.
She gonna make you come to her.
I've been to Maine once.
We shot a music video,
"I Wanna Be Your Maine Man," in 2008.
That was fun.
Fake beards,
just a few hours there.
Ate my first lobster roll.
I've been to Miami twice, I think.
We did some night swimming
when we shot the big box store part
of the "Epic Rap Battle: Nerd Versus Geek"
that was shot in Miami.
And there's a little
throwback to that trip.
Build.com box store.
So,
flew into Portland, Maine.
That was,
originally, we were gonna fly
into like the Northern part of Maine,
'cause it was gonna be Maine,
but then when you're try,
when you're trying to just
get across the country,
you fly to the Southern part of Maine,
which is also like the
airport that you can to from,
you know,
there's no direct flights
from Los Angeles to Portland.
There's a connection in Charlotte,
but we,
because of the time change
we got in
and basically only thing we had time to do
was go to the hotel
to kind of just like,
let's settle down,
and go to sleep, and get
ready for the next day.
But let me tell you,
right off the bat,
I had something that I was like,
well, dang,
this is gonna be quite a trip.
Because we get to our hotel,
and again, just, this is Locke and me.
Locke is 18.
He doesn't look 18.
He has somewhat of a beard.
You know, he is mistaken often.
He could be in his twenties, yeah.
You know.
Mid twenties.
Yeah, so he seemed like
he's in his twenties.
I'm 44.
And I like to think that most people
don't realize that I'm that old.
So when you see us together,
you don't immediately
apparently think father and son.
Okay.
Maybe you do.
I don't know,
and as I tell you this story,
you'll have to interpret
what this person interpreted us to be.
We get on the elevator.
I think I would interpret
you as young pop star
and a manager.
Oh, and I'm the pop star?
No.
And so we get on the
elevator to go to our room
and a approximately 25 year old woman
gets onto the elevator,
and it's just the three
of us on the elevator,
and no lie,
so she looks at us and she looks,
I'll just be honest,
she looks mostly at Locke.
Okay, she looks mostly at Locke.
I'm just gonna be honest.
But she looks at both of us.
She seems to be interpreting us as a set.
And she says before the
elevator door closes,
like as the elevator door closes,
she says, "How long are you guys here?"
And I said,
"One night,"
not really knowing where this was going.
I'm gonna stand here one night.
And then she said,
"We should hang out."
What?
We should hang out.
And it was, I was like, whoa!
The women in Maine.
They've been cooped up.
The boys from California show up
and how long you gonna be here?
So what?
They come on strong.
What'd y'all do?
I guess it's in the lobster.
I mean, lobster,
shellfish is an aphrodisiac.
So apparently,
it is something in the diet.
But I spoke up
and said, well, actually we were gonna go,
it wasn't the final four yet.
It was the elite eight,
and there was a game on
and we wanted to watch it.
'Cause we both care about that.
And then I was like, we
gotta watch basketball.
I just like,
what's the unsexiest thing
that I can say right now?
We gotta watch basketball.
You know, I wasn't gonna
like embarrass her.
I don't know.
Maybe I need to pop my back zits?
I'm his dad.
Less sexy.
Like, I'm his dad.
I could have just said that,
but I decided not to
'cause maybe she would be like,
"Oh, I knew that."
You know, I don't know.
This a Maine woman that's high on oysters.
Well, I think she probably
would've just said,
"I was talking to him."
Well, she didn't say that.
I know.
I'm just wanna bring you down a notch.
So,
no, as I started to say
it from the beginning,
she was definitely directing
most of this at Locke,
you know,
so I was like,
this is gonna be an interesting trip
if this is any indication of
what we have in store for us.
Thankfully we were not
hit on by any more women.
So I can go ahead and give
you that spoiler alert.
Okay.
But that next morning
we wake up and the plan is
to spend some time in Portland,
and specifically kinda walk
around the Old Port area,
which is like cobblestone streets,
like the main, Mainiest
part of Portland, Maine.
And I had actually gotten to know somebody
just like two weeks ago out here
who has a place in
Maine and is from Maine.
Okay.
And had
all these recommendations.
And I was like,
well, the main thing I'm
trying to do in Maine
is get the best lobster roll.
You know, I've had a lobster
roll or two in Maine before
the first time we went.
But like what, in your opinion, as a local
is the best lobster roll?
And he was like, "Even Tide."
Even Tide in Portland.
So I was like, okay, well.
You have your mission.
And he was like,
he also gave a couple
of other recommendations
and like, there's a bakery
that everybody wants to
go to for a cup of coffee
and some bread or whatever, you know,
and a little pastry.
Whatever.
But tell me about Even Tide.
But the plan was,
you know, I kind of
wanted to get on the road
because I had a relatively tight agenda,
meaning that there was a
destination every single night
because there was a hotel reservation.
So unlike the previous trip,
which was thrown together a
little bit more last minute,
and we used like Hotels Tonight
to figure out where we were
gonna stay in that first trip.
This one was like,
I actually want to curate
my hotel experience
and I don't know exactly
what we're gonna do
during the day every day,
but we just gotta get
to these destinations.
Yeah.
So we had some place to get.
And originally my plan was
to just spend a little time in Portland
and then get on the road to Boston,
then eventually Rhode
Island to spend the night.
But when he was like, you
gotta eat at Even Tide
I was like, well it opens at 11.
So we're gonna have to like walk around
and and kill some time in Portland
and get a brunch lobster roll.
So first of all,
Maine is everything
that you want it to be.
You know.
Quaint?
It's beautiful.
It's quaint.
It's gotta, there's a coolness in the air.
It was actually too cold for me
and I didn't bring a heavy enough jacket,
but I, you know, I got through it.
I survived.
But we get to Even Tide,
and I think it's called
Even Tide Oyster Company,
so we did get some oysters.
And like the woman was like,
this place was like not like a,
this wasn't like a hole in the wall.
This was like a hipster, nice place.
You know what I mean?
Like, oh, this community
has got some like really nice,
it's like some place you'd see in LA
in terms of they know
exactly what they're doing
with the design of the place.
It's not like an old
school place that's been,
maybe it's been around for a long time,
but it has the feel of
like a new trendy place,
but just, it has this reputation,
and like Yelp and everything else
confirmed that this is the
place to get your lobster roll.
So the oysters are great,
talking about where they're at
in the different bays
of Maine or whatever.
Okay.
And then
they bring out the lobster roll.
And by the way,
there was a Mythical Beast fan
in the back in the kitchen,
which made me feel good.
Like, I wasn't gonna be poisoned.
We ended up getting like a free cookie.
Okay.
Which was very good.
Take what you can get, man.
But this lobster roll was about this big
and that is about four inches.
That's short.
Okay.
Don't get any wrong ideas.
This is only four inches.
Seems dinky.
And yeah.
And $21.
Whoa!
Is it piled high or something?
It is piled high.
I have a picture of it.
That they're probably seeing right now
if you're watching on video.
I'm not gonna show you pictures
'cause I haven't organized it.
This lobster roll was exquisite.
Now, you know I like lobster rolls.
Was it crunchy or soft?
The bun was soft
in this like, wonderful way.
I can't, I don't even know
what kind of bread it was.
Okay.
And it was the brown butter
like warm kind, right?
So, you know I love lobster rolls.
I had a lobster roll
truck at my 40th birthday.
Yeah.
I like the warm ones
better than the cold ones.
And they would do cold or hot.
And I love the hot, brown butter style.
And the lobster was just perfect.
And I was like, man,
this is a lot of money
for a little lobster roll.
I immediately wanted another one,
but we had multiple
stops planned in the day.
Like, eating was really the
main thing we were trying to do.
And in the process of eating it,
I dropped a freaking piece
of lobster on the ground.
Oh no.
And by my math,
it was approximately $3 and
75 cents worth of lobster.
Ouch!
Was it dirt or linoleum?
Did you pick it up?
No.
Well, we were sitting at a like,
you know, one of those high
bars facing out the window.
And so in order to get the
lobster off of the ground,
I would have to get off of
the stool and bend down.
Cause a scene.
Or use both of your feet.
Oh, let me tell you,
I considered it.
I considered.
That's a shame.
Considered it multiple times,
but I let it sit there.
But then I did proceed to tell the waiter.
I was like, by the way,
there's some lobster on the ground.
Before I had time to
like get up and get it,
I was just like, I just
want you to understand,
like I really value the lobster.
I was kind of hoping he would be like,
well, we'll bring you another piece.
Really?
But.
You trying to angle
for another of lobster?
So, great start culinarily
to the trip, right?
Okay.
And then
we head down the coast
and there's not much
Maine left after Portland
when you're going south,
but there is a place called York, Maine,
which based on my limited research
was a very Mainey-main coastline.
So like we're talking rocky coastline
that has a little trail
that you can walk on,
a little beach there.
Okay.
We actually pull up
and there's a dude getting
out of the water in a wetsuit.
I mean, I can't explain to you
how cold.
Was he surfing?
He was surfing.
How cold it was.
Wow.
And how cold I imagine the water to be.
But you can't keep a Maine man down.
He's gonna surf if he wants to surf.
They're used to it.
They're rugged.
Took a little stroll,
again, met some more
Mythical Beasts on the trail.
Really?
And I was like,
this is interesting.
Huh?
'Cause I bought a T-shirt
in Maine
and the girl who sold me the
T-shirt was a Mythical Beast.
We go to the Even Tide restaurant
and somebody in the back
is a Mythical Beast.
We stop to take a trail in Maine
and we meet like two
sets of Mythical Beasts.
One whole family of Mythical
Beasts on the trail,
and I'm like, well,
you know, I haven't been out in this way
in other parts of the country,
literally in years, right?
Because I pretty much have
been in North Carolina
is the only place I've been.
And your Food Network
show is not even out.
And the Food Network show's not even out.
And I always use,
I use this collectively
as a little bit of a,
it's always a nice little
check-in to be like,
people still care?
Are people still watching this show?
People still listening to this podcast?
And the beginning of the trip
was showing a lot of promise
that yes, people are still engaged, Link.
Just so you know,
I've been, I've gone out,
I've done a report.
People are still watching this show.
People still know who we are.
Did they ask about me?
Yes, I got a number of, Where's Link?"
I was like, I don't have,
you know, he's not currently
being geo tracked by me,
so I don't know.
Mm.
So we drive to Boston.
I was in North Carolina by the way.
Yeah, well, I didn't wanna
give up your location.
I felt like we needed to
do something historical.
Again, this was a little bit
of an obligation type thing.
We're gonna be going through
Boston and Philadelphia.
We're going through
like where the country,
you know, as we consider
the United States,
where things were kind of getting going,
and Locke and I don't care a
whole lot about that history
to be completely honest with you.
So neither one of you were up for it,
but you did it anyway?
No, it was like,
I can take a little bit,
but I'm not gonna like go
on the whole Freedom Trail.
You know what I'm saying?
Like, there's like a two
mile stretch in Boston
that you can just walk
and there's all these historical things,
and you can read plaques
and stuff like that,
and it was like, ah, let's just go,
what's the coolest thing on this?
Paul Revere's house!
Yeah.
Okay.
So we went into Paul Revere's house.
It's like six bucks to walk around.
This thing hasn't changed much.
I felt very historical.
We read all the plaques.
The British are coming.
We considered it.
Yeah.
We read about Paul Revere
and we felt like we had done our duty,
and then we went,
we were actually already.
All right,
what are we gonna eat next?
Right, exactly.
Well, so I didn't know this about Boston,
'cause you and I have been
to Boston a couple times,
but we haven't spent a lot of time there
and we're usually there like
under someone else's guidance,
right?
Yeah, and so I was expecting
more seafood in Boston,
but apparently the north end of Boston
is essentially a Little Italy
and has some of the best
Italian food that you can find.
Hmm.
So I was like, well, I'm
kind of in the mood for that.
And plus we wanted to watch
another one of the basketball games
because the basketball games
were continuing to happen
throughout this trip.
At an Italian bar?
We did.
We went to an Italian
restaurant that had a bar,
sat at the bar and ate.
I drank a little bit,
and we watched one of
the basketball games,
and then we went to another place.
I can't remember.
We had some really good Italian food.
But we had to leave Boston
and get to Rhode Island.
I never, this is one of the
states I was checking off,
you know, marking off of the
list that I've never been to.
Didn't realize until relatively recently
that it is not an island.
Oh god.
Did you think Rhode Island
was an island?
I think I,
it's kind of shaped like Florida.
'Cause when you look at
that part of the map.
It's like a peninsula.
So I guess.
It's not even really a peninsula.
I would've said, sure, it's an island.
Well, this is the deal.
There is an island called Rhode Island
that they call something else
that is a big island that is right there,
and I think when most just
amateur map people like me
look at a map,
they see an island up there
and they're like, that's Rhode Island.
It's really, really small.
You can walk across it in a day,
but no, it's bigger than that
and it's not an island.
So we stayed in Providence, and.
You didn't go to the island?
The proper?
We didn't really have time
because we had a very packed
agenda the next day, okay?
So because that was
Maine day and Boston day,
and then it was basically like,
all we're gonna do is
sleep in Rhode Island.
So stayed in Providence.
I gotta say,
I don't feel like I fully
experienced you, Providence.
I was inside you for a
very small amount of time,
but nothing happened.
It wasn't exciting.
You know what I'm saying?
Nothing happened?
I was just inside and then
I pulled out real fast.
But what I did have is a donut
because it seemed like they
were very proud of their donuts.
In that part of the country,
they tend to be very
proud of their donuts.
Yeah.
And I had a very good donut
and a very good latte.
That was the thing.
Every single day Locke and I were like,
where are we gonna get that latte?
He loves lattes.
I love lattes.
Not coffee,
lattes.
Yes, we are fully Angelino, okay?
I didn't think latte was Angelino.
It's just a lot of milk.
I like a latte.
Yeah, but it's a little fru-fru.
Let's just be honest.
Okay.
Cowboys drink black coffee.
You see Clint Eastwood showing up,
you know, at the campfire
and asking for a latte?
Do you have cream?
Yeah.
I mean, come on, get
with the program here.
It's a little fru-fru,
but I unashamedly enjoy it,
but you gotta make sure
you get a good one.
So we would look up and where's
the best place for a latte.
This place happened to have donuts.
Food really directed your trip.
Food was,
I was like, we both really like to eat
and we both really like lattes,
and so we're gonna be happy.
If you're well fed
you're going to be happy
even if you don't get
to do some attraction
that you thought you wanted to do.
Rather,
better to be well fed
than to be well
entertained with your eyes.
I think I would do the same thing.
I'm not much of a sight seeing person,
especially when there's an itinerary.
Yeah.
I think
I would prioritize the food too.
And I,
it's funny, both of these trips
have done something to me.
Gotten me to a place.
I have a tendency,
and I know you have the same tendency,
to be like, am I really enjoying
this as much as I should?
Did I make the best decision
about where we went?
Did I stop at the right places?
What did I miss?
Did I do enough research?
Are we having as good a time
as we should be having right now?
They call that FOMO.
I constantly ask myself that question.
In fact, Locke and I had a
really great conversation
as we were walking on the Maine coastline.
I was talking about how
I'm having a great time.
This is beautiful,
but I just wanna,
like Locke and I really,
we connect a lot,
and we've connected a lot this year,
which is interesting
'cause we had that conversation
on Ear Biscuits about what
to do in his last year.
And like, these two trips have like,
our friendship has really blossomed.
That's cool.
And we had this conversation
I was telling him about this.
I was like, man, we're having,
we're in this place,
we're doing this amazing thing,
and I'm kind of thinking about what
else we could be seeing,
and what am I missing?
And I had to, like,
I made a decision on
that first day in Maine
to sort of let go of that and be like,
whatever I'm experiencing
is what I'm supposed to be experiencing,
and so I didn't have that
FOMO the rest of the trip.
That's good.
That's very good, Rhett.
But we needed to get to Yale.
Now I wanna be clear,
Locke is, he may be interested in Yale,
but he's not Yale material.
So, we're,
he's not going to Yale,
but one of his really
good friends is, okay?
And so he, we wanted to see him.
We wanted to stop and see his buddy, Ray,
who we've known for years.
And we were like, Ray's at Yale.
I've always wanted to see Yale.
Locke really wants to see Yale
to see what he's not
ever going to experience.
Uh huh.
And you know,
just to see like an Ivy League school.
And I, you know, I always,
I had this visions in my mind
of what a Northeast Ivy
League school looks like.
I've never been to Harvard.
I've never been to Yale.
I had been texting with Ray.
We were on a little group thread
and I was planning the trip,
and I was like, "Hey, what's your schedule
on so and so date that
we're coming through?"
And he was a little slow to respond,
and then we kind of worked it out.
He was like, "Oh, I've got class that day,
but I'll be able to like get
lunch with you guys," you know?
And I was like, "Okay, well I'll plan it
so that we're coming
through around lunchtime."
"Locke and I'll probably
walk around the campus,
check it out,
and then we'll get lunch."
We'll have lattes.
And, well,
the latte already happened.
And,
so we arrive in New Haven, Connecticut,
which is where Yale was,
which is not something
that I could have told you.
And we park next to campus,
and I text Ray,
and I'm like, "Hey, we're here."
"We're gonna walk around a little bit."
"Let us know when you're outta class."
"I'll come get you
and we'll go to this
place that we're gonna eat
that I had chosen."
Consulted with him, but chosen.
Yeah.
For reasons I'll get into.
Ray was like, "What, you're here?"
"Your text said you would
be here on so and so date
a month later."
A month later?
So I was there
on like March 20 something,
and my text had said I was gonna be there
on April 20 something,
because when I looked at the calendar,
I got it wrong.
By a month.
By a whole month.
Oh wow.
So was he even, was he able to meet you?
First of all,
let me just tell you that
these circumstances bring
high amounts of shame to me.
I do not like to be the
guy that makes the mistake.
I hate making mistakes.
You don't know your months, dude.
And I just beat myself up,
beat myself up over it.
So I was like, dang it!
What the hell?
What is wrong with me?
Like, how did I screw this up?
And, but then he immediately is like,
but we were there on a Monday,
which was the same day
that we had planned on.
And so he is like, "You know what,
what a welcome surprise."
"My schedule's the same
as it was gonna be."
"I'll text you when I'm outta class."
Totally fine.
Huh.
So I felt great.
So we meet Ray and it turns out that.
He said, what a welcome surprise?
That's something a Yale student would say.
Yeah, since he's been at Yale,
he's using terms like that, right?
Yeah.
I think he also used the
term sparingly one time,
but he didn't use it sparingly.
Yeah, well, one time is pretty sparingly.
No, he's always been a well-spoken guy
that's why he's at Yale.
So he,
I had been told by the guy
that I knew from Maine,
but also from a little research,
that New Haven, Connecticut
is known best for its pizza.
In fact,
considered to have what
might be the best pizza
in the nation,
and specifically.
Is at a different style?
How do you say that?
Neapolitan.
Yeah, I'd say it that way.
It's that style.
So a pizza about that big
that they kind of put into a,
you know, a wood fire oven.
And apparently this place, Frank Pepe's.
Pepe's?
Pepe's.
Pepe's, Neapolitan.
Frank Pepe's is supposed to it be great.
In fact has been voted
the number one pizza place
in the nation by some publications.
Oh.
So I was very excited about this.
Were they expecting you next month?
No, I didn't make a
reservation thankfully,
'cause I would've been a month off.
And it's a little bit of
like a hole in the wall
kind of outside of the
main part of town situation
and there's another place
that's supposed to be its competitor
that I didn't seem like it was
as good based on what I saw.
Anyway, had a good meal.
I wouldn't say it's the
best pizza I've ever had.
I'm sorry, New Haven.
It was very, very good.
I did get a T-shirt, okay?
It was good enough to get the T-shirt,
but once you get to a
certain level of pizza,
it's sort of like, how
do you go any further?
You know what I mean?
Okay.
I get that.
But interesting thing
that happened at Yale,
so as I explained to you a second ago,
was getting recognized a fair amount.
Got recognized at the Paul
Revere house in Boston, right?
Like, okay.
I'm like, okay, this is
coming down the East Coast,
there's people in the Northeast
who are Mythical Beasts.
It makes me feel good.
But when we get to Yale,
we get outta the car and we start walking
and the students are getting outta class
and there's just hundreds of students.
And I turn to Locke and I say,
"Now Locke,
I don't think I'm gonna
get recognized at Yale."
I was like,
"These students are too
busy and too smart for us."
I mean, I'm just gonna be honest with you.
Oh, you're throwing the
Mythical Beasts under the bus.
I'm not.
Listen, I just think that if
you're at this institution,
you just studying a whole lot
and you're thinking about
things on such a high level
that I'm sorry to say,
I just don't consider
what we bring to the table
in terms of entertainment
to be high brow, Link.
I mean, at times we may sound smart,
but it's a charade.
No.
And I think that,
I'm not saying that the
Mythical Beasts are stupid
by any means.
I'm just saying that,
you know, when we're getting to like
the 0.1% smartest people on the planet,
I just think at that point
they're just not watching
a lot of YouTube videos.
It's my guess, right?
Hmm, okay.
That was my theory.
My theory proved, correct.
I walked past hundreds of students
pouring out of classrooms.
Nobody says a thing.
I felt good that I had been
right in my prediction.
A little bit bad that I had
been right in my prediction.
So.
These people are, they're preoccupied.
They're preoccupied.
They don't have time for entertainment.
But,
so we spend the, again,
a couple of hours between,
we walked around,
like the way that they do it
is they live in these colleges.
There's multiple colleges on a campus.
It's very much designed in the way,
like when I went to Oxford a while back
when I was in London.
Yeah.
When I was in England it's,
you could totally tell,
they were like, we did
it this way over here
and now we're gonna come over here
and do these Ivy League schools
in exactly the same way.
So we like walked through the iron doors.
I mean, first of all,
the campus is just,
you you've been on like
Duke's campus before,
which has this old school feel.
Yeah.
It's like that on steroids.
And the colleges,
you're like, this is where
you live in this little,
you have this little courtyard,
and you walk through this iron gate,
and there's.
Medieval.
Medieval stone work.
Yeah, all this stone work,
incredible stone work,
and then you like passes by the
skull and bones like, house.
Oh really?
This is where they,
this is their meeting house or whatever.
But again, no one's recognized me.
And we finish up, we had lunch with Ray.
We say our goodbyes to Ray
and then we start walking to the car,
and we're we are.
Then a whole group
of Yale students says, "Surprise!"
"We did know who you were!"
50 Yards from the car
Locke turns to me, he's like,
"Dad, I actually didn't believe you
but you were right."
"No one at Yale recognized you."
The moment,
the moment he finishes
the sentence I hear,
"Rhett!"
"Rhett from Rhett and Link!"
"Holy!"
Oh, wow.
That's a very sophisticated response.
And there was a guy who
I think he recognized me.
A little, a little bit.
And continued to just
be like, "Man, holy!"
"Rhett from Rhett and Link!"
So it was just like, the enthusiasm.
Made up for the?
You know,
I could get recognized by no one at Yale
and to have one guy say, "Holy,"
when he recognizes me.
Right.
Passionately.
It just, it changed my whole view of Yale.
It changed my whole view
of the Ivy League system.
There's hope.
Yeah, there's hope.
For us.
I will continue telling you the story.
There's a lot more cities.
There's a lot more stories on the way.
But we do wanna talk about
"Inside Eats With Rhett & Link,"
our television show.
I mean, it's been a while
since we had a television show.
It has.
We do this about every 10 years.
So yeah, we go behind the scenes.
We get unfettered access.
Well, we're kind of fettered.
There's people there who are watching us,
but we go to like test kitchens.
We go to headquarters of
your favorite eateries,
food places.
So I mean, Chipotle,
Cheesecake Factory,
we also went to Cool House,
an amazing ice cream shop.
That's, I'll call it syndicated.
Beyond Meat.
We were the first people
to ever get access
to film behind the scenes at Beyond Meat,
which is really cool.
So we learned a lot
and had a lot of fun.
So it's this interesting mix of comedy
and food experience,
and access,
that creates "Inside
Eats With Rhett & Link"
10:30 PM. Food Network.
Same time.
It's launched on Discovery Plus.
The extended versions
are on Discovery Plus.
Yeah.
So check it out.
We've been saying things
like bonus footage,
but that makes you think
that you're gonna have to like watch,
click on something
else, and it's like, no.
The episodes are longer
and have things that we had to cut out.
Extended versions.
To get to the 22.
Extended versions is the right word.
Yeah.
So, check it out.
We're on Food Network.
We're doing it.
And I think, and we're just being us, man.
Just being us, man.
Eating stuff,
having a great time.
Check it out.
"Inside Eats."
Okay, so left New Haven.
The plan is to head to New York
and look at a school in New York
that Locke is interested in.
Oh, wow.
Yeah, 'cause that,
I was picturing Rhode
Island and Connecticut,
south of New York state.
Nope.
I dunno why.
It is funny how the geography sort of.
Gets jumbled up.
Coalesces in your mind
as you're driving through it.
The other thing that you realize
is that unlike any place
that I've ever lived,
the concentration of population
in major cities is so high,
so much higher in the
Northeast than anywhere else.
Like, once you get to like North Carolina,
you're gonna be driving a while
before you get to a
major metropolitan area.
But when you're up there,
you're gonna go from like Portland,
to Boston,
to Providence,
to New Haven, to New York, to Philly,
to Baltimore,
to DC.
Like, there's just a bunch of big cities
right there next to each other,
because it's where it
all started, you know?
How long were you in New York City?
So we get to New York in the afternoon
and you know, we're the McLaughlins,
so we did not plan any official tours.
Let me just say you.
You saw him in New York
City, not New York state?
New York City.
You should plan official college tours.
I'll explain it in a second.
If you're gonna do,
if you're gonna,
because with this campus in particular,
it's a pretty secure campus.
Hmm.
And when we tried to
just walk into it,
we were stopped by security guard.
He was like, "You can't
just walk in here."
I was like,
"Well, he's been accepted here."
And he is just like, "No, I mean,
no, you can't do that."
"It has to be like an official thing."
Hmm.
And I was like, "Okay."
So we ended up traveling into Manhattan.
Scaling a wall?
Traveling into Manhattan
and spending the night
and then setting up a
tour for the next day
to drive back out of the city,
to go to this school for an official tour.
So that was a little bit of a
hiccup in our travel schedule,
but it didn't really matter.
So that,
I'll tell you about that in a second,
but that night we go to
lower East side of New York,
which just happens to be
where we end up staying
like every time we go to New York.
Yeah.
Which is a great spot,
really high concentration of
great restaurants and stuff.
When you have an 18 year old with you,
you can't go into bars
and you can't like go into comedy clubs.
There's a lot of things that you can't do
when you have somebody under 21.
It's like, oh, this is interesting.
I haven't thought about this.
But what you can do is go to restaurants.
So we like did the whole
food tourist type thing,
when you go to a restaurant
and you just get a couple
of things and you leave
and you go to another restaurant
and get a couple of things.
I just, I,
this style of vacation
has really like opened
a whole world to me,
this road trip vacation,
where you just drop into a city
and eat a couple of things at
a few different restaurants.
It might be my new way of vacationing.
It's just, I don't necessarily mean
a full top of the nation
to the bottom of the nation road trip,
but it might be like,
I'm gonna land in one state,
spend a couple of days in this place
and I'm gonna go to this other state
and this other city.
Like, this dual city thing.
So I'm definitely floating
this idea with Jesse.
Well you're getting ready for Europe then.
That's how you can do Europe.
Yeah, exactly.
So, we spend some time in Manhattan,
have some great food,
then we go back, we do the official tour,
which was illuminating,
'cause we'd done some unofficial tours.
But like when you can like get
into the buildings and stuff,
and like,
you don't have to like, wait
till a student opens a door
and then run in behind them.
It's much better.
And then you also get to ask questions
to people who have
experience at this college.
Okay, yeah.
So I felt, I was like, oh man, this is.
Lesson learned for Shepherd
is what I kept telling Locke.
I was like, okay, well
me and Shepherd do this.
I'm gonna do it better
than I do it with you.
Hmm.
Okay.
And you don't have to,
you don't have to do what I did.
If you have a kid, do official tours.
You're probably already thinking that.
Now, I knew I wanted to
drive to Philadelphia,
and again,
we were gonna go to Pat's and Geno's
and eat a cheese steak from both places.
Oh, both places.
So, the thing was to
take Locke to this place
where I've got this experience
from making this video in 2008.
Yeah.
On the Alka-Seltzer
Great American Road Trip.
And I was like,
we're gonna taste these cheese steaks
and then you're gonna help me determine
which one's the best,
and then we're gonna get
the T-shirt from the place
that we think has got
the best cheese steak.
But,
I hear a but coming.
So we go to Geno's first, okay?
The flashy one.
Flashy, orange color,
you know, he's the one
that's the big personality,
a bit of a controversial
character as well.
I think he had a sign
on the door for years.
It was just like, if you
can't order in English,
don't order at all or something like that.
I think it's since been taken down,
but I was like,
okay, but these are the
classic cheese steak places.
We're gonna get one from both of them.
We get up to Geno's
and immediately
the guys who are cooking
the steaks back there
who are not old enough to
have worked there since 2008,
these guys are in their twenties.
Yeah.
Are like, "Rhett!"
"Rhett from the video.
From the video?
Yeah.
Oh, wow.
They all see the video.
So it's not like Rhett
from Good Mythical Morning.
It's just like this video
apparently is something that
if you work at Pat's and Geno's
you've seen this video.
And so then they were
like, he knows what's up.
He came back to the right place.
And I wasn't about to say,
I'm going to Pat's right after this.
So we get one cheese steak.
Now, first of all,
Locke's a little bit picky, okay?
And I kind of knew
this was gonna be a little
bit difficult for him
because I was like the way
that they suggest you order it
is with Cheez Whiz,
and he was like, "Dad,
I can't eat something
with Chez Wiz on it."
Like, he just won't do it.
And so I was like, all right,
well you're probably right.
Let's get the one with provolone.
It was just better anyway, right?
That's what I thought.
So we get like,
you know, there's a special
way you have to order it.
They're not as strict at
Geno's as they're at Pat's
about saying it all in the
right order or whatever.
But we get it, and we
split it, and we eat it.
And first thing I'm
struggling with is like,
this is not that great.
Just gonna be honest with you.
I'm like, I've had a lot
of great cheese steaks
and I've had a lot of good sandwiches,
and I was just like.
Yeah.
This is just not that great,
but it's pretty good.
But it's not, if I made
a cheese steak at home,
if I threw something
together with some good bread
and some cheese steak meat,
like I'd be getting pretty
close to this, right?
And Locke's like,
"Yeah, it's good."
"It's pretty good."
So then we go to Pat's,
and I tried to,
I went around the back to try to,
I didn't want them to see
me just go over to Pat's.
I felt a little self-conscious
'cause they had a,
"You chose the right place!"
'Cause you can see 'em from each other.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
That's right.
'Cause they're two adjacent corners.
Yeah.
So we go over to Pat's,
and our first thing I do is
I order from the wrong window
like a moron
because there's a drink
and everything else window
and there's a cheese steak window,
and there's a very particular way,
and you're supposed to say it in an order.
It's kind of a little bit of a,
I mean, at this point.
It's a pain.
It's part of the.
It's a test.
The vibe.
They make this thing with provolone.
I gotta be honest with you,
at Geno's they put the
provolone and the meat together
and it kind of melted.
At Pat's, they put the provolone on
after they put the meat on there
and it was just like not
melted into the meat.
And then.
This one isn't good either.
We sit down, Locke takes one
bite and he spits it out.
Oh my gosh.
And I take a bite and I'm like,
oh gosh, this is actively bad.
Oh my gosh.
This is actively bad.
I remember Pat's being better.
That's what I thought!
I'm just saying.
And again, you can't judge.
They've gone downhill, man.
No, I have a theory and
I have a conclusion.
I have three conclusions
I came to on this trip
and one of 'em is about Pat's.
Okay.
Okay?
My theory is,
now the thing that you see all on Pat's,
all on the advertising,
is about how they're the first place.
They're the guys who
invented cheese steaks,
the original.
That's what it says all over
in like all these different fonts,
or like written many different times
in many different ways.
If you've been doing
something the same way
for, I don't know, 50 years,
well, the American palette
has been transformed
significantly
and people are eating
better and better things.
As Locke said.
And I wholeheartedly agree with him,
he's like,
"Dad, the Big Kahuna from Jersey Mikes
is like five times as good as
either of these sandwiches."
And I was like, "You are 100% right."
The bread is better.
The meat is better.
The cheese is better.
The way they do it is better.
If you're just doing something
to do it the same way.
And let me tell you,
no crowds at either place.
I didn't have to wait at either place.
I bet it's only tourists too.
So here's my conclusion,
and I hate to throw,
listen, I'm a fan of what you've done.
I'm a fan of the tradition.
I went there.
I purchased a steak.
I did not get a T-shirt from either place.
I didn't feel like either
place stood up to the standard.
My challenge,
my conclusion is that one of the places,
Pat's and Geno's,
if they actually want to
end the cheese steak wars
once and for all,
they need to publicly admit
that it's time to change
and they need to reinvent
their cheese steak
and do it in a way that reflects
the evolution of the modern palette.
And they need to bring
out a new cheese steak
and be like, listen, we did
it the same way for 50 years
and now we're doing it the right way.
And all of a sudden, the
other place will be leveled.
The other place will never recover.
If you got the cohones,
or the cohones to do it, do it.
That's my conclusion.
When I was in North Carolina,
we went to Highway 55,
formerly known as Andy's Cheese Steaks
when we were growing up there.
Got some new facilities next
to the Bojangles in Lillington.
It's better.
That is a good cheese steak.
It's better than Pat's and Geno's.
Oh yeah.
I came to two other conclusions
that I'll fold into this
because the other one
happened on the same day.
I had noticed by this point
that there were multiple times
when we needed to use the restroom.
Okay.
When you're traveling, you
need to use the restroom.
And when you're in a city,
there's no public restrooms.
There's no public restrooms.
And there's so few public
restrooms in America.
But you're always eating at a restaurant.
In Pat's and Geno's they
don't have a bathroom.
Hmm.
We had to piss.
We've been drinking lattes, man.
Big lattes.
Yeah.
Eating cheese steaks,
drinking Pepsi, or whatever it was.
I think I know where
you're going with this.
I gotta piss, man.
And then we start talking about like,
I mean, I had to piss so bad,
am I gonna find a place to piss?
And Locke's like,
"You can't do that
because you don't wanna get
arrested for public urination."
That would be bad.
That would be a bad look, you know?
I would love that.
For you.
And then I was like,
I actually think I could
live this one down.
I think this might be good PR for me,
'cause it's not real serious,
but I was like, "Yeah, you're right."
So we actually had to do this in New Haven
and then we had to do it again
where you go into a place
and you purchase something
in order to use the restroom.
So in New Haven we went to
a Subway and got a cookie
so we could use the restroom.
That hurts.
And in Philly we went
into an Italian restaurant
and I asked for one garlic knot.
Apparently that is,
you can't get one garlic knot.
They gave me four.
So four garlic knots
or one cookie equals one urination.
Actually two urinations.
Say,
I want the bathroom special.
Yeah.
And we did eat the cookie
and we did eat all four garlic knots,
because why not?
You've got 'em there.
And then I came to a conclusion.
I was like,
this didn't happen to me
when I was in Australia.
Because everywhere you go in Australia,
there is a toilet that
you can put a coin in
to access a public toilet
that requires a little
bit of money to use.
Paid public restrooms.
Now whether they're free,
and whether they're subsidized,
or whether they're paid,
America needs more restrooms.
They need more public restrooms in cities.
I just don't get it.
I think they can turn all
of the defunct pay phones
into toilets.
Little, walk in closets.
I mean, remember in Amsterdam,
you'd walk around this like
spiral thing to the center
and then you would pee and it would,
and from your shoulders up,
as a six foot tall person,
from my shoulders up,
I was just looking at the landscape.
Yeah.
At the urban landscape.
People were peeing.
I could make eye contact with
people while I was peeing.
No, I don't like that.
But you could not,
you couldn't see me peeing
but you could see my face.
You might see me peeing.
And tell that I was peeing.
I dunno.
And you could also
see my shoes in some of them I think.
And I think there was like a toilet there,
but yeah.
And there was no, it was just like a,
there was no door.
It was just like, kinda
like a snail shell.
What ends up happening?
I love that.
What ends up happening in American cities?
And I'm sure this
happens around the world,
but you know, homelessness is
a big issue in American cities
and it's only gotten worse
through the pandemic.
So you've got these unhoused people
who gotta use the bathroom somewhere.
And so, but these restaurants are like,
I don't want this homeless
person coming in here
and messing up my bath bathroom.
And so you gotta purchase
something to use the bathroom,
customers only,
and then it creates situations
where the homeless people
using the bathroom,
they're sometimes on the street.
You know, in LA there's like,
they'll bring like a porta
potty or something like that
out there, but.
I thought you were gonna say
that you were gonna get like a Go Girl.
Like, one of things, well, for.
Oh, I have one.
For girls.
I didn't bring it though.
It works in such a way that.
No, I have a wide mouth.
I mean, it's, I mean, I'm not bragging.
I'm not bragging.
You have a pee Nalgene.
No, I have a thing that is,
it glows in the dark.
I talked about this before on a camping.
Non-portable Nalgene.
It's a glow in the dark
thing with a handle
that you can pee in during
the night while camping.
I love that idea.
And I should've
just brought that.
Should've brought that.
But you could have bought.
We would have one per person.
Yeah, but you could have bought
like, a big container.
Well here's the other thing,
the third conclusion I came to.
That's the thing you need.
The third conclusion I came to
because I love these things,
is one of the things they
have in the Northeast
is these travel centers.
You know about the travel centers?
Yeah, like a truck stop.
But.
It's a gas station.
It's a rest stop that has a whole,
it has multiple things.
It is a gas station.
Right.
A convenience store.
Yeah.
It is a electric car
charging station,
and it is a food court
with like a Starbucks,
and a McDonald's,
and a KFC, multiple places,
and then a bunch of places to sit.
And of course, really nice,
very large, very clean bathrooms.
It's like a capitalistic rest stop.
And I just gotta say,
we need more of these
in the United States.
It's just, because.
This is the platform you're running on.
Coin operated toilets and
travel centers everywhere.
And travel centers.
It's just, it's such a missed opportunity.
Like, rest stops are okay
but the travel centers just
make you feel so American.
Okay.
Well, I mean go as long as you want,
but we're still in New York state.
Oh yeah, yeah.
Well, you know what,
the pacing of my conversation
goes with the concentration
of Metro areas,
which again is very, very cluttered
at the top of the country.
Okay.
So from there we drove.
Well, I guess we were in Philly.
We drove to Washington
DC to spend the night.
Oh!
This may have been the highlight, okay?
And let me just say,
I wasn't expecting DC to be the highlight.
And you know, I've been to DC many times
and I've seen all the monuments
and the stuff that you see,
and it's just like,
it's always kind of
cool, but it's not like.
I can't guess why DC.
Well, I'm gonna blow your mind.
It has to be the food, obviously.
It's all you did.
Well, so Washington DC
has great Ethiopian food
'cause there's a very
large Ethiopian population.
It's really known for
some great Ethiopian food,
so we picked the best place.
I knew this was gonna be
a little bit of a stretch for Locke.
'Cause again, he's picky
and picky people don't like
to venture out into places
like Ethiopian food.
I think I would like Ethiopian food.
So it's essentially a bunch of meats
and vegetables and stuff
put on this big pancake
and then you take another
piece of the pancake
and you pick it up and eat it.
It's exquisite.
I love it.
But it's the kind of thing
that I don't wanna do it all the time.
And it was like satisfying,
great, whatever.
Well, we had some plans for the next day.
I originally planned that
we were gonna wake up early
and go basically see the monuments, right?
We stayed in a hotel pretty near the mall,
Washington, the mall,
and he thought that was,
until I clarified,
he thought that was like a mall-mall.
No, this is not a mall, son.
We're not shopping.
This is a place where
all the monuments are.
But then I'm looking,
it's like 10 o'clock at
night after we finish.
We had gotten there late.
We ate a late dinner,
got some dessert at another place.
Again, we would like go
to two different places.
That was the MO.
And I'm like,
these monuments are open 24
hours a day and there's lights.
That's cool.
And I was like,
let's go see all of them right now
in the middle of the night.
That's a good idea.
So we took an Uber to
the Jefferson Memorial,
which is on like the far
side of the Tidal Basin,
which I didn't know
that's what it was called,
but that's the giant
lake there in the middle
that all the monuments are
around right next to the mall.
That's the Tidal Base.
Okay, the shallow swimming pool?
No, no.
You're thinking about
the long, manmade thing
that's directly between
the Lincoln Memorial
and the Washington Monument.
Yeah.
I'm talking a giant lake.
Oh, okay.
So we go to the Jefferson Memorial
and there, and again,
this is probably like 10:45,
11:00PM at this point.
There's one family in
the Jefferson Memorial
and they leave.
So we have the entire
Jefferson Memorial to ourselves
and I never.
What are you gonna do with it?
Deface it.
No, we were like talking about how like
there's all these cameras
and there's cops around.
Not that we actually wanted to deface it,
but I've only ever seen this stuff
when there's a bunch of other people
and it's hot,
and it was cold.
It was like, kind of uncomfortably cold.
And that made the crowds really low.
People were like,
why am I gonna go in the middle
of the night when it's cold?
But these things are
designed to be seen at night.
The lighting is incredible
and there's like this solemn sort of feel,
and I was like,
this is going to be amazing.
So we go clockwise around the whole thing.
So we stop,
so like, Jefferson Memorial
and then there's like,
there's others stuff that I
hadn't never really seen before.
There's a whole FDR section.
And then there's a whole MLK
section, which is amazing.
I think that might be the most recent one.
That's newer, yeah.
I haven't seen that.
And then going around
hitting the Lincoln Memorial,
which there was probably
like 10 people there.
Like, you can't get the
Lincoln Memorial to yourself.
There's just two popular.
But like, we like sit,
we stood up there on the stage
and we had just seen the
Martin Luther King Memorial,
and then we go stand
exactly where he stood
when he gave his speech.
And we're just talking about like,
when he gave this speech,
like, if you could have told him like,
listen, you're gonna be
remembered as this great man.
And you know, matter of fact,
there's gonna be like a 40
foot statue of you over here
almost within eye shot,
and you're gonna be killed
for saying these things,
you know, by the government, most likely.
You know what I'm saying?
It's like the,
it was just kind of surreal,
and Locke and I were like
having really great conversation
about a lot of things,
but there was a,
I got this weird feeling of,
I'm gonna use the term,
I'm gonna use the term patriotism,
but let me contextualize that.
You know, our country is so divided.
Like, so viciously
divided right now, right?
Yep.
And people on both sides of the argument
think that the people on the
other are legitimately evil,
right?
Like, that's the point
that we've gotten to.
Like, we've gotten so polarized
that we think that the other
group of Americans is evil.
And there was something about
like being there at this time
and seeing these,
and listen, our country
is just riddled with,
it's a complex, complicated history.
Like I said, the fact that
you've got this giant statue
of MLK right next to the
place where he spoke,
and then like,
we know for a fact that the FBI
didn't want him to be alive,
you know?
And so we know that our,
there's so much complex history,
but something about being there at night
and seeing these things that like,
we did this thing.
We started this country
and it's supposedly
built on this principle
of the equality of all people,
and we put these things
in this giant, grassy area
to like, symbolize this,
and it was just,
there was just something
kind of moving about it.
And strangely, this sense of hope
that like, I obviously like
looking at the Washington Monument.
It isn't like, the fact that we can build
this giant.
Obelisk.
Obelisk into the sky means
we're gonna get through this,
but naively maybe,
is kind of, this is what it made me feel.
I was like, all right, we're
gonna get through this.
And this big, giant-ass thing
is gonna still be in the air.
Hmm.
But.
So it worked?
Aside from yeah, the propaganda.
I told Locke.
I was like, the propaganda
is working very well
for this guy.
Like, I'm very susceptible to marketing,
but the whole thing is
just marketing America.
And I was like, you got me.
Like, I believe in this principle:
equality for all people.
Let's make it happen.
Let's come together and make it happen!
Mm.
But regardless of your
political affiliation
and what you think about what I just said,
let me just tell you,
go see 'em at night.
Go see those monuments at night.
It's just awesome.
Locke told me that it was a
highlight of the trip for him.
That's awesome.
He had no idea
that it was even gonna happen.
It's like, you're going up to each one
and you're like, where
is the food in this one?
Okay, so the distance traveled each day
is about to increase.
We drove to Charlottesville, Virginia.
My nephew, Locke's cousin, goes to UVA.
We took a little tour of UVA.
Cavaliers!
What a beautiful campus, by the way.
I love college campuses.
I love the idea of college campuses.
College was a great experience for me.
And I love just that,
just this city kind of just
exists for this university
that's been here forever.
We went to Edgar Allen Poe's dorm room
because he went to UVA
and they still have it like preserved
in a way that he would've
had it when he was there,
and you can like, look.
The door is glass and
you can look into it.
Huh.
Met several Mythical Beasts at UVA.
Then we continued on down.
We actually picked up Eli, our nephew.
Brought him with us in North Carolina.
He needed a ride.
Okay.
So we took him to North Carolina,
but we met the family,
you know, my family,
my parents, and my brother, and his family
all hung out at the new cabin
that we got in North Carolina.
And we also picked up Shepherd
to now take Shepherd all the way to Miami,
so it's three McLaughlins now.
That was a plan to pick up Shepherd.
Leave Jesse in North Carolina.
She's like doing some design work there,
at least going to like the
High Point furniture thing.
Oh.
She's living her best life
in High Point.
And then Shepherd,
so Shepherd's coming with you.
Yeah, and I had told the
boys that first stop.
Is a latte.
Well, yeah, of course.
So after the lattes,
but the second stop
is not the, but a Creation Museum.
What?
Uh huh.
Yes, sir.
Thank you to roadtrippers.com.
Again, I use that service again.
Still paying for it.
So you must have gone.
Nobody reached out
to give it to me for free.
You left North Carolina
and you went to where?
Where is a Creation Museum?
Southern Pines.
Southern Pines, North Carolina?
Yes.
So the Creation Museum,
the Ken Ham, Answers In Genesis
Creation Museum in Kentucky
that has a full scale Noah'a Ark.
I haven't been there.
I would love to go.
I love this kind of thing.
I know Southern Pines.
Sidebar.
If you know my story,
I used to be a Christian.
I am no longer a Christian.
One of the reasons I'm not
is some conclusions I came to
about the historicity of the Bible.
But creationists, and
hardcore creationists,
like young earth creationists
believe,
and this isn't all Christians.
It's a fair amount,
but not all,
believe that everything you
read in the Bible is true.
And Noah's Ark was a real thing
and Adam and Eve were a real thing.
Evolution didn't happen.
People.
True, literally.
Yeah, true literally.
It is a literal,
historical account, right?
And so when I heard that
there was a Creation Museum
in Southern Pines,
which have you been to Southern Pines?
It's where, I mean,
there's a golf course there
that's really nice.
That's all I know about it.
Near Pinehurst
where some of the best golf in the world.
Southern Pines is true to its name.
A bunch of pine trees
and like this very historic, quaint town.
What is at the Creation Museum there?
Well, the Creation
Museum is in a Christian,
that's the name of the sign says,
The Christian Bookstore.
That's the name of the place.
It's inside a bookstore?
So you go into the bookstore
and then immediately down into the left
there's steps that go down,
and you can tell,
obviously tell you're entering into
what feels like a Southern
Rainforest Cafe kind of vibe.
Oh.
Because essentially
it was this pastor who has since died,
but they've kept it alive.
They've kept the museum alive.
It is basically a collection of taxidermy
of everything you can imagine.
What?
And also a bunch of tools.
So it's the Creation
Museum and the tool museum.
And it shows up on like
roadside attraction type stuff,
because it's so quirky.
Quirky.
What?
This are just normal animals?
There's like a North Carolina section,
which is like everything that you can kill
in North Carolina, they're on display,
but there's also just like
mostly American things.
So it's just like,
look at all these, God made this animal.
Look, God made this animal.
But then there's little exhibits.
Like, pretty early on
there is a cabinet that is a glass cabinet
and there is nothing
inside of the cabinet.
And on the top it says,
"Inside this cabinet
is all the credible
evidence for evolution."
So it's things like that.
But there was a little snake with an apple
inside the cabinet, which was like Satan,
the serpent inside the cabinet.
Oh.
Now this guy was like
serious about all this.
Like, he didn't necessarily
have a sense of humor
about any of this.
And I didn't know how the people
who currently run the Christian Bookstore
were going to feel about this.
'Cause I'm obviously
coming in there as a guy
who's like, I disagree with everything
that you're talking about.
Wild, man.
But I like,
I'm fascinated by this mentality
and I understand it
'cause I've known so many
people who believe this
that like this will be a
fun thing for us to do.
And I'm not going in
there to make fun of them
to their face.
I mean, obviously we're going
in there to be like, what?
This is crazy.
We're kind of laughing,
but I'm not gonna laugh in their face.
And I was also like,
you know, how much does it cost?
And they were like, "Whatever
you think it's worth."
Ha.
And so I did drop 20 bucks
into the donation thing.
I'm like, I'm gonna come here
and I'm, you know what?
I'm gonna send a lot
of people to you guys,
because if you are in Southern Pines,
go to the Christian Bookstore,
look at the Creation Museum.
It's fascinating.
There's a whole section.
It's very,
it's kind of crazy how much
crap this guy collected.
He collected these tools
that I didn't even ever
really figure out what it was.
They looked like levels.
He was really like,
he's got all these old,
certain type of tool.
Like, found antiques?
But a whole bunch of the same thing.
Like, hundreds of the same thing.
And I'm like, I don't even
know what this thing is.
I'm afraid to ask.
You're not a placard reader.
But there is a section
where you'll go down a little hallway
and come to this glass case,
and it'll say, these are the things,
these are the other gods
that the world worships.
And it'll be like, like country music.
What?
And then it'll be like a guy
on the front of a muscle magazine,
or like a woman,
but not a woman in a bikini,
but like suggesting like
these are the other things.
But then mixed in with the vices.
So country music,
muscles, and sexiness.
But you know, the worldly pleasures.
But mixed in indiscriminately
where the worldly pleasures
is like something that represents
like an African tribal religion.
Like so like other
religions, like Buddhism.
So like, yeah again.
Okay.
You gotta understand,
I totally understand this way of thinking.
I used to kind of think
this way growing up.
You thought that all these other religions
were essentially like satanic
expressions of things.
They weren't like,
somebody's like heritage
and the same type of
thing that you had done
and come up with your own deal.
Yeah.
You thought that
they were wrong and you were right.
And so you could put them along
with all these other vices,
like worrying too much about your body,
or caring too about food,
or caring too much about music.
And the boys were fascinated.
They were just like, what?
I don't.
They couldn't process it.
They were like, I don't
understand what he's saying.
I'm like, no.
Well, let me understand.
He's saying that everything
outside of God and Jesus,
as understood
in a very particular
interpretation of the Bible,
everything outside of that is wrong.
That's what this guy thought,
and that's what a lot of
people still do think.
It's the source of a lot of strife.
And you gave him $20.
And I gave him $20, right.
So we saw the Creation Museum.
Highly recommend it.
And then we were on our way
to Florence, South Carolina,
to stop at this hole in
the wall barbecue place
that I had read about.
But little did I know,
that kind of coming from Southern Pines
and getting to Florence, South Carolina,
we were gonna go right
past South Of The Border.
This was an unintended stop.
So if you've ever been on I-95
going from North Carolina
to South Carolina.
You got sucked in, huh?
You see,
well, you can't not stop there
when you're on a road trip with your kids.
Yeah.
Now you see all the signs that.
Every mile there's a billboard.
Let me just, I'm just gonna.
Stop and see Pedro.
I'll just give you an idea.
Mascot.
This is a, definitely
highly racist stereotype of
a Mexican man named Pedro
who wears a giant sombrero
and has a mustache
and is welcoming you to South Carolina
as if you're passing
from America to Mexico.
It was somebody's grand idea
many, many decades ago
to like have this
Mexican-themed play land.
There's a motel there.
There's a putt putt place there.
There's a giant Pedro with
a giant sombrero tower
that you can go into.
Yeah.
So we stopped there.
How is it still?
It's not doing well, man.
I mean,
we literally were inside the souvenir shop
and the power went out.
Like it just, the whole
place just went black.
I guess they shut down while we here.
You witnessed the end.
We witnessed the end
of South Of The Border.
Wow.
But the boys, again,
you know, they're growing up in
much more informed times than we did.
And so like, they're just like,
"Dad, this is like so racist."
I'm like, "Yes, son."
"I did not realize that
when I was your age,
but you've been educated differently."
So we decided to not get a T-shirt.
I was like, I, you know?
Okay, yeah.
I don't really wanna play
into this whole thing,
but it's still there
and it's become a little
bit of an artifact.
Yeah.
In and of itself.
But we were gonna go to
this hole in the wall,
barbecue place.
Now I just heard about this place.
I'm actually I'm torn with mentioning it
because I don't, it was,
the barbecue was very, very good,
but the guy is like,
so politically,
he's really just set himself up.
His barbecue put has become
like a political statement.
Oh.
So you can find it if you want to.
You're not gonna have
to do too much research,
but I won't give 'em the free advertising,
but the barbecue was impeccable.
Really?
Mustard based?
It wasn't.
So mustard based is kind of isolated more
to the Columbia area,
and we weren't going through Columbia,
and so I was,
they had a mustard base
that you could put on things
that we did kind of get,
but the barbecue,
we got pulled pork sandwiches
and they were pre-sauced,
but sauce in a good way.
And just, and pretty finely chopped.
So very similar to North
Carolina in that there's,
like, it's not pulled pork.
It's chopped pork,
which is not my preference
if I'm doing it myself.
Yeah, me neither.
I like to make whatever
I'm eating in the moment
my preference,
'cause I have a lot better time with it.
So, and I did that and it was exquisite.
It was great.
It's a food truck that is
next to a dining facility,
like a dining room
on just this random road.
Like a shelter.
No, it's like, you could have
put the restaurant in here,
but you didn't.
'Cause you want to drive it away?
But there's a pool table
in the middle of it,
and Fox News was on,
on the television,
and then we all purposely
sit right next to
'cause we were the only ones in there,
a giant picture of Donald Trump.
The picture was so big.
What?
That when you're next to it,
it was like,
you couldn't even tell what;
it's so pixelated.
Like, you could see that they
had printed this thing out
and then they did not have a
picture that was large enough.
The resolution of the Trump picture
wasn't large enough for this sign,
but it says,
it's got Republican with a check box,
Democrat with a check box,
and then Trump with a check box,
and it's checked Trump,
and hasn't checked Republican or Democrat.
Wow.
So that's the statement
that this guy's making.
And there's a lot of other
questionable paraphernalia
and some stuff on the wall
and that kind of thing.
But the thing is, is that,
that is what the south is
in a lot of ways, right?
Like if you get outside of the cities,
that's where you,
that's the mentality that
you're gonna run into
into a lot of the people.
And I was just basically
just telling the boys,
I'm like, this is,
man, this is where I come from.
Like, this is our background
and this is the barbecue
that the they make.
And I'm not gonna just
not go there, you know,
because they've identified
with this racist soul,
but you know,
it was a little bit of an
eye opening experience,
but they also kind of loved it in a sense.
Not love for what that dude stands for
and what the mentality that those people,
but it's almost like going
into a foreign place.
Yeah.
Now when you're living in Los Angeles,
you don't get to see that, you know?
Right.
And we have the privilege
as three white dudes just
rolling through the countryside.
I'm not worried about my safety.
I might get some side eye
because of my hair or whatever,
or the clothes I've got on.
Yeah.
But I'm not gonna,
my life is not in danger.
I don't feel unsafe.
I don't feel like I need to
make sure I'm in my hotel
before the sun goes down.
Right.
Which if my skin was a different color,
I might feel that way.
So I recognize the privilege
of being able to like
go and experience these things
in almost like a historian,
like an observer,
like a journalist type way,
because I can just come back
to my bubble over here in Los Angeles
and not have to see any of this stuff.
But great barbecue.
If you happen to figure out where it is
based on what I just said.
We stopped in Savannah, Georgia.
Again, now you're talking like,
you see how quickly we're moving, right?
Yeah.
So we go from North Carolina,
we're in North Carolina,
we eat lunch in South Carolina,
and then we're in Savannah,
Georgia for dinner.
Savannah's cool.
Savannah is awesome.
I was actually, I know
Birmingham is really cool.
Savannah is a different thing.
Savannah, I don't think.
Savannah,
it's on the ocean.
Oh yeah.
We've been, university, no.
Have we been there?
I've been to Savannah before,
but I don't know if I was with you.
I don't think I've been to Savannah.
Savannah is everything that you imagine
in terms of like the deep south
with the mossy trees and the humidity.
Again, the temperature
had changed significantly
by the time we get down here to Georgia
and it's basically, there's
a small part of Georgia
that's on the coast,
and Savannah is there.
There's like Augusta at
the top and then Savannah.
Okay.
And Savannah is old,
and beautiful,
and it kind of has a
little bit of a Charleston
meets New Orleans,
kind of like,
there's just, there's a high concentration
of really great things to eat.
Lots of things to do.
There was like a music festival going on.
There's like soul food,
Southern cooking restaurants
on every single corner, right?
And of course we didn't know
when we were gonna be there,
so I'm not doing any reservations.
I'm just like getting there,
and maybe there's a place
that I've researched
ahead of time.
But like, we like walk into places
and it was like, we don't have any tables,
but we did find a place,
and that's what I wanted to give you.
This is what we ordered,
just to give you an idea of the food.
We had low country, mac and
cheese with shrimp and sausage.
Oh!
That's what Shepherd got.
I got gumbo and grits.
Which had everything from
gumbo and cheese grits,
and Locke got country fried bison.
And we did just kind of shared it all.
Country fried bison sounds strange.
It was like country
style steak, but bison.
So it was a little bit leaner.
It was incredible.
Wow.
I highly recommend Savannah,
and that's when it started to hit me.
I was like, man, me and
Jesse would have a good time.
Me and Jesse would have a better time
than me and the boys are having here
because it's got that sort of like,
there's a little bit
of romance in the air.
It's supposedly the most
haunted city in America.
So if you're in like the
ghost tour of it all,
there's a bunch of people going around
in like, on a ghost tour basically.
Oh, okay.
Just so much history there.
And then we ended up spending the night
in Jacksonville, Florida.
So we got all the way to Florida,
from North Carolina to Florida.
Again, it's like so much more time passed.
Oh wow.
Or much more mileage
under our belts in the
second half of the trip.
We spend the night in Jacksonville,
which by the way I learned
is the city by area
in the continental United States.
It's 840 square miles.
Jacksonville, Florida is 840 square miles.
Is that on the coast?
Yeah.
It's on the east coast of
Florida at the very top.
Basically right when you get into Florida.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, I've only have passed through there,
but I guess it did take a while.
Don't feel like I gave
Jacksonville its due.
We just got to a hotel late
at night and stayed there
and then got a latte and got out.
The latte was pretty good.
But we wanted to get to St. Augustine.
Oh, the oldest city in America.
Yeah, so St. Augustine was.
My dad's been there
a few times.
He always talks about how
much he loves it down there.
The grass!
I could totally see your dad loving it,
and I gotta say the sort of
middle aged white dude in me
kind of loves it too.
Like there's something
that kind of draws you.
There's old houses,
there's golf,
there's grass.
Yeah.
You should see
the blades of grass down there.
And the food in all these places,
you're getting in just to like
the best food in America, you know?
I mean in St. Augustine,
you're kind of getting,
so St. Augustine has a Spanish influence.
I learned so much history.
I didn't understand how
old St. Augustine was.
But they basically like
built that mission there
like a few decades after Columbus,
like we're talking like
1530 or something like that.
They're basically like,
this is a town now,
Spaniards.
And then I also didn't
realize that the Spaniards
owned Florida until the 1800s.
Did you know that?
And maybe the late 1800s.
It's weird.
I just didn't understand.
We didn't take great history
and I didn't pay attention to it.
Well, you got the Louisiana Purchase.
Yeah, that was when
Louisiana was purchased.
We're talking about Florida.
And then Florida was after that?
Florida was like one of the
last stands on the East Coast.
It was the last thing on the East Coast.
Hmm.
There's a weird thing
that happened with Key West
and like the Confederacy at some point,
and the Confederacy used the
Fort there at St. Augustine,
which we toured at some
point during the war.
I don't know, man.
It's a cool place.
There's a lot of history there,
but we were heading to Miami,
and this is when we started.
We actually had been listening
to this ahead of time,
but I'm gonna go out.
I'm gonna break this out.
This is my reck for the week.
Okay.
Have you heard Keith
Whitley's "Miami, Miami?"
Yeah.
Which is
his number one song.
It's actually bigger than
"When You Say It Best
You Say Nothing At All."
I don't know it that well,
but I know that it
sounds like he's saying,
"Miami, my Amy."
Miami, my Amy.
Is gone or something.
He thought was gonna be gone,
but she, he's in LA.
The thing is,
is that he's in LA and she's in Miami
and he's on a plane to Miami to see her.
And Miami, my Amy loves me after all.
It is an amazing song.
We listened to a lot of Keith Whitley.
We got into, you know.
Tear jerker.
He died.
He died at 34.
Yeah.
We listened to a lot of Keith Whitley.
The boys were really into Keith Whitley.
I wonder what he died from.
Locke said alcoholism,
when he looked it up on Wiki.
That's sad.
So we started playing like, Miami,
like as you're driving towards Miami
and you're playing Keith Whitley,
it's just, everything
is falling into place.
Much better than the Will
Smith, "Miami" route.
Yeah.
Still a fan, but I never liked that song.
Well, speaking of songs,
I talked about this in the
AMA that we did the other day
for the Mythical Society,
but I love to play music that is regional,
whether it's, you know, if
we're heading through a town.
So like Dawes has a great
song, "St. Augustine At Night,"
which we listened to in the morning
because that's when we
were in St. Augustine.
Hmm.
We kind of hated
that we weren't there at night,
but that's a great song.
But listening to Miami,
and then we're heading into Miami
but I had a little surprise planned,
and that was to stop and take
a fan boat on the Everglades.
No!
Really?
Oh, you did that?
And I did it.
Oh man!
I'm so jealous.
That's the one thing that I've
wanted to do before I die!
Yeah, well, I've always wanted to.
Now you can die.
I've always wanted
to be on a fan boat,
and I did.
So you made plans.
I made plans.
Okay.
And I almost
didn't get there in time.
Man, so the Everglades are really big
and they start pretty high,
but they end in the bottom in Miami.
So you're gonna take a fan boat to Miami?
No.
So I was basically, there
was multiple locations,
but I was like,
I'm gonna drive to the
one that's next to Miami.
So we're kind of like
almost done with our day
and we do this like late
afternoon fan boat ride.
Oh, okay.
And shout out to the people
at Saw Grass Recreational Center.
They have a little reptile zoo
and then they have the fan boat rides,
and they're a few Mythical
Beasts on the staff there.
And we,
I learned some things.
So we get, it's just the three of us,
and the dude operating the fan boat.
How many seats were on there?
Six?
There's three rows of bench
seats with no seat belts.
Oh?
No, there's nothing over you.
It's just like a bench and
you just gotta hold on.
And so Locke and Shepherd
sat in front of me
and I sat behind them.
It's super loud.
They give you earplugs.
Oh, we didn't wear 'em 'cause you know,
we're in Florida.
We'll lose our hearing.
It's fine.
And then it's super loud,
but he's like, man,
he's lived there all his life
and he's explaining.
I'm like, "So, do you guys have like?"
You know, first of all,
we're gonna see some gators.
He was like, "Yes, we're
gonna see some gators."
And we did.
And he was like,
"They're active at this time of the day."
"It's mating season."
So we probably saw.
Gators mating?
12 alligators in the wild,
some really big ones.
And then he was explaining, no, he did.
We said, have you ever seen 'em mating?
He was like, "Just the other day
they were mating when I showed up
and they rolled into the water."
We didn't get to see any
gator sex as much as I wanted.
I think they charge extra if you see that.
It's like a little
retroactive thing, but then.
It's like putting a
foot into a gator boot.
And then,
but I'm asking him about,
I'm just kind of noticing
that it's all water.
I mean, yes, there's a,
it's like two feet of
water and there's a whole,
it looks like land,
but I can kind of tell
that it's all water.
There's no like, land.
And he's like, "Yeah,
the bottom half of the
Everglades is 600 square miles."
Not as big as Jacksonville.
Maybe it's 6,000 square miles.
That makes more sense.
Oh, so you didn't have
any like the Cypress trees
or whatever those trees.
Right,
he says, "That's the land
that's gonna have some trees and stuff,
it's further north."
And he says,
"And that's where all those
invasive pythons are."
The ones that have like taken over
the whole Everglades
because of people
letting their snakes out.
Wow.
Their pet snakes.
He said, "I've only
seen one down here ever
because they want some land."
But then he likes telling us
about the history of this area.
'Cause there's also this
invasive species of bird.
He was like, "Yeah, like in the nineties,
there was a hurricane and this bird
that's from another place in the world
got out from some zoo,
and now they all live around there
and the gators love to eat 'em."
And so like,
it's just cool to cool
to see like the ecosystem
and how, I guess how screwed it up it is.
Were there paths?
Because there was reeds everywhere,
with paths, right?
We were going through
some obviously natural sort of canals,
but there was one really
long, straight canal.
I was like, "Now this
isn't natural, right?"
He says, "No,
actually a hundred years ago or so
the Army Corps of Engineers
decided that they were going to drain this
and put cows here."
And so they put the cows out here
and it was an absolute disaster
because it was like super muddy
and they couldn't keep
pumping the water out.
And so then they just let it fill back up.
And but one of the things that happened
is there are these little
tiny pockets of land.
Like, I'm talking like big
enough to put a house on,
that people could come out and claim.
So he took us to this island
and there was this island
that we didn't go on,
like, we drove,
we rode up to it,
and it was this house on this island.
What?
With this giant Trump flag,
of course,
like, this is Trump country,
and this guy has just set up his,
he lives out there full time.
Off the grid.
No power, of course.
He has his own, like, I
think he's got solar panels
or something,
but like, it's just his land
'cause you could,
at some point in the past
you could just claim it
and they got grandfathered in
and never had to pay for it.
And so he is like, "Yeah, this
guy is like 70 years old."
"He's retired. He lives out here."
"And he bought a fan boat from us,"
from the place that I got the fan boats.
And so he has this transportation
on his own fan boat
that he goes back and forth on the land,
just living out there.
Completely isolated.
And surrounded by alligators
by the way.
Surrounded by them.
Wow.
So it's wild, man.
So if we had to do it again,
you'd be up to go to like
the northern Everglades
'cause it's a different experience.
Yeah.
Where the woods are.
I mean, I'd also do that again.
I mean,
I don't know.
I may be going back to Miami a lot.
Locke hasn't made a decision about school,
but that was the final destination
was to tour the school that
he's interested in Miami,
which we toured,
and it was beautiful.
But the last piece of the trip here is,
so we,
oh, that night we go,
we went to Miami Beach.
Which again, if you remember
the geography of Miami,
there's a pretty giant downtown
that's on the coast, right?
And then there's an island
that is out from the coast,
which is where the real beach is.
And that's like where we
stayed at the Fontainebleau
and stuff like that
when we did that event.
Okay, yeah.
And that's where like the beach is
because there's not much beach at all.
'Cause it's pretty much mangroves
that come all the way down
to the water in most places.
So there's not really a shoreline
except like a traditional beach,
except Miami beach has a heck of a beach.
So that's where we went, you know,
and we stayed in Miami Beach.
Yeah.
We did the night swimming.
So night swimming
was on the agenda.
Oh!
Now we ate some incredible food.
Miami has so good,
the food is so good.
We ate at this like,
it was like Cuban, Peruvian
fusion or something.
I don't know what it was, man,
but it was unbelievable.
It may have been my favorite
meal of the whole trip.
I mean the food on this trip,
I just love eating so much.
I should have a show on Food Network.
So Miami, you enjoy it while you can
before it all goes underwater.
Yeah, that's what I keep thinking
when I see it.
I'm like, man, you know,
this is not gonna be around,
but it's around now.
And we go to the beach
and I was like, "Guys,
one of the best experiences
in my life is night swimming."
And one of their favorite
songs is "Night Swimming."
We have songs that are
like top to everything
and then boys.
REM?
Yeah.
And so I was like, all right,
we go down there,
now I don't remember
what time of year it was
when we night swam with
Stevie, and Ben, and Alex,
and not Alex Punch, but Alex Alexandrof.
Yeah.
But it was hot.
It was hot.
And the water felt like a bath.
And you couldn't tell the
difference in the temperature
between the air and the water.
Not so much the case in early
April when we were there.
So Locke was scared of sharks
and it didn't feel great.
It felt great outside of the water,
but it was kind of a little chilly,
like when the bath's a little bit too cold
kind of situation.
Okay.
But I was like,
you guys have to get in
and sing at least the
first verse and chorus
of "Night Swimming" and then get out.
So they did that.
And then that was the last,
so we were what we were supposed to do,
night swim,
then go stay in our hotel,
then tour the campus.
Couldn't get an official tour,
but this campus was an open campus
so we, you know, we could tour it anyway.
Official tours were like booked
or not available on a Saturday.
But there was a convergence of events,
and that is
that we knew that Carolina and Duke
were playing each other in the final four.
That night.
That night, Saturday night.
And this is the night that
we're supposed to come back,
and I bought these
flights a long time ago.
Now I'm super conflicted
because I'm an NC State grad.
I do not like Carolina.
I do not like Duke.
I do not like Carolina more
than I do not like Duke,
but this is like watching,
as I said on Twitter,
the two popular bullies in school fight.
It's like, I don't like either one of 'em,
but I'm showing up for the fight.
Yeah, even I watched it.
Right.
And if you don't have
any context for this,
I mean, this was the most
important college basketball game
in the history of college basketball.
'Cause this is what might be
the biggest sports rivalry.
I think was actually voted
the biggest sports rivalry
over the Red Sox and the Yankees
by Sports Illustrated back in the day.
I don't know about that,
but it is for us the biggest thing.
And they were gonna be playing
literally at the same time
that we were on the plane,
and getting off of a plane,
and getting onto another plane.
And I was like,
Locke is a huge fan of basketball
and he really wants to watch this game.
I'm a huge fan of basketball
and kind of want to
begrudgingly watch this game.
So you pulled an Eric Church.
I changed the flight.
I was like, we're gonna watch this
and we're gonna fly out in the morning.
So yeah, we,
this wasn't,
didn't have quite the
repercussions of Eric Church's.
Barbara, quit scratching over there!
What you doing?
Why you gotta be a troublemaker?
Why can't you be like Jade
and just sit in my lap the whole time?
So, we changed the flight.
We watched the game.
We watched the game,
we watched the first game, the Villanova,
not the Villanova,
whatever the first game was.
I've already forgotten it.
It was Kansas
and whoever they beat.
I can't remember.
And watched
that first game in a bar.
And then we were like,
the second game, we're gonna watch it
in the comfort of our hotel room
so we can get as loud as we want,
even though we're not really,
I wasn't,
Locke was pulling for Carolina.
You were,
you better be pulling for Duke.
So, this very interesting
thing happened to me,
and I talked about this.
I saw your tweet tweets.
I was like, what's going on here?
Well, here's the thing,
I've lost some of my,
I think that one of the things is,
I, for many years now
I've been able to step
outside of the real passion
and emotion that I have around sports
and understand that it is fake passion.
That it is the way I feel about sports
and the competitiveness of like,
if NC State's playing somebody,
the way I feel,
like my brain in my body
doesn't know the difference between
a life or death situation
and NC State sports.
That's what sports is like
for someone who really cares about it.
Yeah.
And I understand
from an outsider perspective,
that seems crazy
because it is definitively crazy
to care that much
to the point that years
are coming off your life.
You're doing things that
are bad for your health.
Maybe getting yourself into a situation
where violence happens,
because to other people
or maybe to a wall,
because you care so much about this stuff.
And something about being in LA
and also my life filling up
with so many other things
that like, I'm just like,
I still care about this,
but it's really hard
to get passionate about
NC State athletics
when it tends to be just a marathon
or merry go round of disappointment
a lot of times, right?
So, and especially when
it comes to basketball
and you live in the shadow
of Duke and Carolina.
All these people in my
family go to Carolina.
My wife went to Carolina.
My brother goes to Carolina.
My nephew goes to Carolina.
Locke wanted to go to
Carolina, but he's not.
And so, and I was also like,
I wanna see Coach K go out with a win
because I used to be a Duke
fan when I was in high school
for no other reason than
I just like picked a team
'cause they were good.
And I was like, I'd like to
see Coach K go out with a win.
But then you just kind of look at this
hobbling, North Carolina team
where they've got seven guys who play.
They got this new coach, Hubert Davis,
who I like as a person.
They're playing hurt.
They're an eight seed.
It's just like, it was
hard not to pull for them,
but in the end I was,
I got to a place where I was
literally 100% indifferent
to the outcome,
but still nervous at the same time.
I had this weird, anxious
energy watching it.
And I was like,
you know, if Carolina wins this game,
it'll be crazy.
If Coach K wins this
game, it'll be fitting,
and like, he'll go out on a high note.
And so in the end when Carolina won,
I just kind of felt just
an empty nothingness.
And I was like,
I changed my flight for nothingness.
I altered in my entire schedule.
I paid extra money so I can watch
an emotionally, just non-gratifying.
You know what I'm saying?
It was just such a weird thing.
I was like, I'm so glad I
watched this historic game,
but I got nothing from it.
It was like eating a burger
that's made out newspaper.
Eh.
I don't end your entire
trip account on that front.
I mean, why don't you
end on something else?
Well, that was the end of the trip.
But let me just say,
we had an incredible time.
Some of the, you know, I couldn't,
I've already gone for an hour and a half,
but some of the conversations
that we got into,
like we got so tickled.
Like, now with Shepard being 13,
the nature of the conversations
and the funny things that we talk about
and the way that we make each other laugh,
it's just, I really value that
time that I have with them.
We just have a good time.
You're all on a 13 year old level.
Yeah, right.
It's like, we're all
now on the same level.
And so,
boy, we just talked about so much weird,
philosophical, existential, funny stuff,
and just, you know, they're
both very passionate
and have a bunch of
opinions about everything,
just like somebody they're related to,
or two people they're related to.
And I just had the best time.
And Locke and I, we,
the funny thing is,
is Locke and I had such a great time,
and then the very first
night when Shepherd shows up,
Locke's like, Shepherd
was doing something,
like he was getting in the shower
and he like left something.
I was like, "Don't do
that with the towel."
And Locke was like,
"Shepherd, don't screw up our system."
"Dad and I have a system
that we have established
and you can't be messing up the system."
I was like, I'm proud of him.
I didn't even tell him it was a system,
but he picked up on the
fact that we had a system.
We were in a rhythm.
You used
the top half of the towel.
He used the bottom half of the towel?
Well, yep.
Well, usually there's two,
but yeah,
Shepherd was,
Shepherd was invading on
the system a little bit,
but he eventually fell in line.
Well, I'm glad you guys
had that, you know?
It's something you'll never forget.
And if you do, just
listen to this podcast.
And that is the thing I was thinking about
as I'm experiencing something
like a trip like this.
I'm like, man,
there's an impulse to write it all down
because you know, you take pictures,
you take video,
but you want to encapsulate
the whole thing.
Well, you know what?
Hold that thought
'cause I think there's a lot
there that I do wanna unpack.
And there's something
that I've experienced
that I hinted to you a little bit
that I think leads to an
entirely different podcast
that I keeps you should access that,
so let's put a pin in that.
But that's why I didn't write it down
because I was like,
I'm gonna talk about it
for an hour and a half
in great detail.
Somebody just needs to transcript it
so I can read it as an old man.
Let's just post it online.
Yeah, let's do that.
As a audio.
Just release this as a podcast.
Video.
Again, my reck,
"Miami, Miami" by Keith Whitley.
And Keith Whitley as a
general recommendation.
Just a guy who was
doing some very special,
specific country in the
time that he was alive.
In the eighties.
And then he passed away in 1989.
And did you know that he actually had a,
he and Ricky Skaggs were in
a bluegrass act together,
and if you listen to Keith
Whitley eventually on Spotify,
'cause he doesn't have that many hits
'cause he didn't sing for that long,
you get down to the album
where he and Ricky Skaggs did
and his voice is completely different.
Doesn't sound like Keith Whitley at all.
That's strange.
It just sounds like
a dude singing bluegrass.
Barbara wasn't with us.
Say goodbye, Barbara.
Bye-bye!
#earbiscuits.
We'll see you next week.
To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon
to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your Mythical best.